doesn't Trump in-house Republicans say
their plan for a sweeping tax overhaul
will give the middle class a big break
we are giving them a big beautiful
Christmas present in the form of a
tremendous tax cut it will be the
biggest cut in the history of our
country House Speaker Paul Ryan says the
average family of four would save nearly
$1,200 a year
the proposal would add one and a half
trillion dollars to the country's debt
over a decade Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with how Democrats and some
Republicans are now pushing back Nancy
good morning good morning an independent
analysts have been crunching the numbers
they say that many but by no means all
middle-class families would get a modest
tax cut it all depends on things like
where you live and whether you take the
standard deduction so it's difficult to
draw across-the-board conclusions about
winners and losers here's what we can
tell you that this plan introduced
yesterday reduces the number of
individual tax brackets from seven down
to four the corporate tax rate gets
slashed permanently from 35 percent to
20 percent and there is no change to
limits on 401k contributions or
charitable giving a few Republican
Congressmen have come out already
against this bill because it eliminates
the deduction for state and local income
tax they argue that's going to hurt
people in high tax states like New York
and California and New Jersey where home
prices are also among the highest in the
nation Democrats are attacking the plans
elimination of deductions for medical
expenses and student loans and they're
also against a new cap on deductions to
new mortgage loans which would be cut in
half from its current million dollars
down to five hundred thousand they say
that's going to slow down the entire
housing industry still Republicans are
plowing ahead they say it's possible
they could make some changes but they
want to begin debate next week because
the president is pushing them to get
this pass in the House and Senate by the
holidays led